okay I want
do you know the history
all right are you who voted you said you
voted
no oh you guys didn't vote you did we
voted for Obama but we did not vote I
didn't vote for that I was not old
enough to vote okay at that time okay I
was just I'm just I'm just curious can
you name one policy from Obama no I told
you I didn't vote for an hour the right
way yeah you might you might you seem
like what a policy of Obamas you liked
who like you know like he wanted to like
nobody passed anything he did something
for lgbtq rights right exactly but that
wasn't why I voted for him but yeah that
was the one the big one that everybody
voted for him because he passed [__]
proposition eight but that wasn't you
know yeah yeah I think gay marriage just
got to be banned we got a band yeah
[Music]
what do you feel about transgenders
wanting like naturally born females that
say you're 100 equal because I got a big
old stand on that wait what what you're
definitely born okay transgender I'm
gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna talk about the
gay marriage and then I'll and then we
could talk about the trans people okay I
think that we
so right now there's an issue where
there's below a replacement rate and I
think marriage is supposed to be a
Sacrament when I hit the lower
replacement so so you need three kids
roughly like you need at least I think
like half the women having three kids to
replace the population so there's issues
that happen in a society when there is
an aging population when like there's
basically too many old people that can't
work now the young people are coming and
we don't have people to fill these jobs
that's paying people to move there
because the elderly are dying correctly
so I think we need to push policies that
promote family unfortunately you know
gay people can't produce children I know
they can adopt but these days they're
such a long waiting list for adoption
they I mean they could but I don't think
that's ideal either because I really do
think you need a man and a woman in the
household that's just my my belief I'm
Catholic and I and I really do think
that marriage is a religious like
Sacrament and so I think when you're
kind of deluding and ruining the meaning
of marriage when you're you're having it
become between a man and a woman not a
man and a man or a woman and a woman I
don't really give a [__] what people do
in their house like go have fun be crazy
you know what I mean but it's like when
you're taking something that's religious
and like calling it something else I I
just I'm a Catholic it doesn't say right
with me me and my girlfriend have talked
about it and if we did end up getting
married we would want us to find like a
high value man who was cool with being
our baby daddy you know what I mean
where she would be the one [__] the
kids out I don't wanna [__] do it
um okay yeah he would be involved
I don't think it's any worse than well
raised by one moment I agree I think I
think that a single mother household I
think all the kids should be given to
the dads
yeah because I think if let's do what's
best for the kids and all of the data
will tell you that single father homes
turn out better than single mother homes
let's give the kids to the Dad what's
best
I think I think again um it disrupts the
natural order of the world women we get
our periods we're emotional and so it's
like you know I just I think it's really
cool yeah especially young men you know
and that's why if you look at all the
problems in society we can go off of
data we could go off of what I see in
real life like there's a homeless
shelter down the street from where I
live in England and I asked them like
why like why are these people homeless
like what got them in this situation and
he said the number one reason is because
of single mother homes if you go to the
criminals it's the same you go to um
Juvenile Detention Center same thing if
you go to insane asylum same thing so
it's like we have this one common
denominator where single mother homes
have all the issues in society really
come from it and I I think that evil
happens when you disrupt the natural
order of the world and unfortunately
there's propaganda there's government
policies that really disrupt the natural
order of the world which is that we are
supposed to submit to men we cannot be
here without men they do all of the hard
jobs in society they make all of the
money in society it's supposed to go God
men women children so so on a single a
single black woman's home 74 of the
women that have children the single
homes or black women right in a black
household right so when they get
divorced 74 of the single homes or black
mother that the children are 20 times
more likely to go to prison nine times
more likely to commit crimes five times
more likely to be in poverty this is
data from the Census Bureau this is the
[__] we're making up and so when you
look at that you you see what I'm saying
and I'm not look I don't hate on anybody
a gay straight trans or other I hear
what Pearl's saying but the point is is
that everything that's going on right
now is anti-prolife like there's more
black babies getting destroyed by
abortion than black children are being
born right now in America well I'm glad
that I contributed to society I have
four children I have three girls and a
son two of my daughters are married I
have three grandchild children one on
the way so like I've contributed to
society I have been a single mother I
have raised them and my children did get
married
um fairly at a young age and I'm good so
but that's good see that's an exception
do you think your your kids would have
preferred to have their dad around their
dad was around no do you think they
would have preferred to have two parents
in the same home yeah of course
absolutely okay so so you did like you
would agree yeah I don't think no kids
there were times where it's like okay
for a short period of time it wasn't
anyone in the home but at the same time
I don't think like you know bashing the
the child's father or anything like that
to leave the door open for them to have
a relationship just because you didn't
have a relationship with them doesn't
mean that the children shouldn't and
that's a real problem we have
women bashing the dads and making them
out to be evil when when most of the
time the women that do that they're the
evil well I can say you don't think that
the dads ever bashed the women because I
know personally because men no they do
do that my dad bashed I also know my
uncles That Bass they're like baby mamas
and everything it'll happen I'll give
you I'll give you an example okay so I'm
doing uh statistics no I'm not it's
they're not distorted um it's just based
off of so I'm doing a documentary on
divorce and and the thing is when you
interview people like hundreds and
hundreds of people you just start to see
patterns and the issue you as women have
all the power in divorce courts and it's
very easy for a woman to accuse a guy of
abuse with no evidence so they'll say
and the issue is when feminists get into
Industries the first thing they do yeah
the first thing they do is they switch
the definitions of things so I'll give
you an example one thing they did that
with was rape it used to be forced sex
what is forced sex that's easy to tell
someone's on top of you you're saying no
blah blah blah but what they switched it
to was sex without consent that makes it
subjective so because what is consent
that makes it consent like it's
different for each woman right and you
it and ended that so no not now what
happens is women infiltrate Industries
and they switch the definition so what
they did was they they switched the
definition of abuse and they expanded it
and they got sexual assault they added
in financial control coercion all of
these words that don't really mean
anything and women can go into Family
Court which is based on a balance of
probabilities which means there's one
judge not a judge and a jury of his
peers he doesn't get to face his accuser
and it's basically not like normal Court
which Inc Criminal Court you need
evidence you need to convince a jury and
and in family court it's just one judge
which you know you cry it's a lot of way
easier to do that and so what happens is
a lot of these women they go to court
they accuse the men of abuse and then
they basically say that the men did a
lot of things that he didn't do and I've
even seen cases where a woman is trying
to get a man to hit her and she still
got custody like that that's how
one-sided the court is and it's it's uh
because they actually raped them and
then they're like well what is what and
the question is what is it we'll talk
about that what is what is rape and
that's the problem is they've switched
the definition where we don't even know
what it is anymore well Pro to go back
to what you were saying about how the
women can uh influence the children
because my father did have other
children and they can't stand like my
father because well he's he's passed on
now but they couldn't stand him because
of what their moms were telling them
about the dad but my mom never gave it
gave me that Side Story even though she
had maybe similar experience to their
mothers but it did not stop me to say
that oh I don't want to have a
relationship with my father et cetera
Etc so I do know that yes women do have
a lot of influence on like the
relationship between children that's
just my personal experience like and men
just don't have the tendency to do that
like men suffer in silence it's a lot
more like there's things women use
social manipulation men are more likely
to use like physical well actually I
think more and more but guys are
starting to be more like that because
they're they're like down low gay as
[__] and they just take on such [__]
ass Tendencies well yeah they do gossip
and they talk [__] well a lot of times
a lot of them I really think that most
evil comes from women and I think it
goes back to Adam and Eve I know this
sounds crazy but let me finish because
who did the serpent talk to he's talked
to Eve and and all of the big changes
that you see in society it's all from
women for voting for in my opinion evil
policies I think it's evil I think
abortion's evil yeah and what they'll do
is they'll show women and they'll show
they'll show women they'll show women a
video of a 12 year old that can't get an
abortion and we just run to the polls we
just we're like oh no not the 12 year
old even though that's like very much an
exception because women were really easy
to propagate with social media and I
know because I interview all these
hundreds of women they tell me the same
arguments that I hear from all the
different women from social media it's
so easy to manipulate us when we're not
under the authority of men because men
are just more logical beings the
abortion thing is really hard because
like it depends like if the girl was
raped and she's 12 years old of course
you you feel like she should be able to
get one but then I see so many [__]
that are like 32 and they're on their
18th abortion can we sign up
you need to get arrested
what are the part where a one out of
three women has had an abortion and like
to me that's crazy that's crazy and it's
less than two percent or one percent or
from but also that is qualifying
underneath an abortion though even like
like does that count that's what I want
no no plan B Plan B doesn't count okay
what about like an ectopic pregnancy
does that count as an abortion uh those
are so weird they're not rare they're
very common yeah
I think that's that's people actually
like pass away if you have if you have a
next topic yeah yeah but I think
oh
compared to how many
millenniums there are it's not it's not
fair that it's all on the woman though
because the men have male birth control
has been a thing and they're like oh no
no the issue the issue with male birth
control is like they made it they Market
it this is what they do they do like
this false propaganda marketing the
reason those men died from male birth
control
yeah it wasn't it wasn't what they're
yeah yeah yeah it wasn't like just side
effects it was isn't it
what a vasectomy is reversible I think
it's I think it's reversible after the
first year it comes the whole 50 less
reversible or something like that as the
time goes on okay so so basically though
my point is
my my my point is like I just think that
a lot of I think that comes like when
women when women get power we're not
nice with it we're not even nice to our
own kids we kill them that's a crazy
thing and that was before abortion was
even legal women were the number one
people to murder their kids in the 1800s
I think they murdered like 10.
depression well we always make up an
excuse and that's what the feminists do
is they'll just make up some excuse for
the women
but my thing is okay if we want to say
that okay women if we want to say that
women aren't as accountable as matter
there's some reason that they did it
then we're not equal and we have to have
policies acknowledging that we're not
equal but if we're going to say that
we're equal then be equal have the same
consequences as a man but we keep seeing
these women throwing their babies in a
dumpster there's no there's no
consequence for it as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible